non moi j'aurais demandé d'interstices
pense que à l'automne on devra se
vacciner 12 étages et les plutôt content
je parle où les gens fragiles ou les
gens malades les gens très grec mais
aussi pour les journalistes encartés
globalement il faut arrêter que la
stratégie dont on fait des mesures
généralisée pour tout le monde et les
mesures généralisée c'était le
confinement vaccination pour tous etc
pour passer à une stratégie
personnalisée accary donc ça doit gérer
entre le médecin et son patient et donc
si le patient a plus de 80 ans ou plus
de 65 ans est globalement au dessus de
65 ans et bien il ya plus de risques en
dessous de 65 ans et puis les gens
fragiles les gens immunodéprimés
l'obésité c'est un facteur de risque
majeur mais en tout cas faut arrêter de
prendre des mesures qui concernent tout
le monde il faut revenir de la médecine
de bon sens de la balance bénéfices
risques est donc dans ce cas on est
d'accord qu'on est contre la vaccination
obligatoire à partir d'aujourd'hui la
vaccination obligatoire je pense qu'elle
est plus dans le débat de même que la
quatrième dose elle est plus dans le
même vin la vaccination des enfants non
plus face à n'a pas de sens quand je
parle de balance bénéfice risque c'est
que je donne un médicament ou un vaccin
et je suis pro bac et provoque ce pour
les gens fragiles qu'il faut protéger en
revanche les gamins qui ont participé à
l'ennemi à l'immunité de tout le monde
qui nous ont protégés les enfants
n'étant contaminé il faut pas aller les
vaccinés en sec l'immunité naturelle
elle est supérieure elle est plus
durable que l'immunité post vaccinales
donc profitons les gamins plutôt
déculpabiliser un an tu vas tu es papy
mamie profitons du fait qu'ils ne font
pas de maladies graves et ils vont faire
des antiques fureur notamment des
anticorps ou weight mon protégé tout le
monde gerald même question d'une
spéciale géopolitique valérie bègue est
ce que à terme on aura à faire d'autres
vaccins une fois par an parce que comme
on fait le vaccin de la grippe et on
devra y retourner régulièrement une fois
par an peut-être mais encore une fois
chez les gens fragiles le vaccin de la
grippe c'est plus de 65 ans aux femmes
enceintes personnes obèses
immunodéprimés ou insuffisants
respiratoires ou rénaux donc ça veut
dire on à risque de maladies graves ont
fait le vaccin est peut-être qu'il
faudra leur faire sûrement sachant que
attention les anticorps on sait pas
mesurer l'immunité donc c'est pas parce
que vous avez des anticorps élevé que
votre immunité a été levée on sait pas
ça on sait pas le faire en routine on
aime question fruits et légumes 2
bonjour vraiment de rungis non non moi
ça à la question faut-il avoir peur moi
je dis faut-il être inquiet moi je suis
inquiet parce qu'un témoin kg et
inquiète t
inquiète hôtel très
inquiète parce que là bas quand ils ont
dit on ferme des villes des villages
s'est tout de suite 9 millions et bien
sûr nous on sait pas quand on sait tout
de suite on ferme ile de france pour
représenter ccsa donc je me dis donc si
ça arrive là-bas peut-être que ça va
arriver chez nous et je suis inquiet
parce que je ne veux pas remettre les
masques je ne veux pas ressortir des
passes sanitaires pour aller au
restaurant je ne veux pas qu'on remarque
nos enfants je ne veux pas que nos
enfants passent sept heures du matin
jusqu'à 17 heures le soir avec un masque
je ne veux plus de tout ça donc oui je
suis inquiet nous tout ce que tu veux
plus voir doter toutes
choses que je veux du maréchal harper
débit n'est pas le danger et puis mais
la peur est mauvaise pour le système
judiciaire qui est parce que le stress
c'est mauvais pour notre système
immunitaire est depuis deux semaines
c'est fait matraquer et du stress et je
pense qu'on devrait donner une bonne
dose d'optimisme sur la mara est ce
qu'il ya des raisons d'être inquiet
pour qui tous les français ou pour les
chinois pour les français et pour les
chinois bascou ont alors pu blesser je
pense pas parce que les chinois ne se
quittent plus leur territoire l'accord
téléthon c'est déjà mieux ils sortent
pas rien en revanche vous l'alpr 700 cas
c'est une très bonne facture pour
gouverner le pays aussi le temple pas du
tout inquiète pas inquiète alors je fais
confiance à notre gouvernement